for many people living with cancer the
last few weeks have been a holding
pattern I'm Lesley I'm 54 and I've got
advanced breast cancer I'm Martin I'm 64
years of age and I've been diagnosed
with kidney cancer I'm Bradley I'm 22
and I've been diagnosed with testicular
cancer I've already been told that if I
need surgery on the lung and that's
likely to be delayed by a couple of
months because of resources being
alerted to the Corbitt virus I got
booked in for an operation to remove my
kidney for weeks as yesterday and then
it got cancelled the day before because
of me
the main problem that we had especially
with the corona virus was they didn't
know who ever or not they could do the
treatment cancer treatment of all kinds
as being cancelled or postponed
sometimes because it's too risky for the
patient's immune system if they got
covert sometimes to free up beds the
head of the NHS says today the urgent
and essential treatment must still go
ahead this hospital the Royal Marsden
has no covert patients and act as a hub
for cancer treatment but these don't
exist across the country and there's
another problem the number of people
going to their doctor or any where
they're diagnosed with serious illnesses
has plummeted it looks as if we are now
coming through the peak of the corona
virus in patients and so we've got a
spare capacity in hospitals across the
country and that means that as well as
other critical and urgent services we
will be able to restart some of those
more routine services that the NHS is
also here to provide cancer experts say
tens of thousands of cases are going
undetected they're almost certainly
going to lose more patients
unnecessarily from cancer than we do
from covert 19 and that's because much
of the whole pathway has been disrupted
from patients not feeling they can
present to their general practitioners
for good reasons not wanting to disturb
the NHS we know the two-week rates down
patients who are then having their
screening appointments cancelled
Marton faces a four month wait but
Bradley's chemotherapy
is now underway you must feel it's very
cruel timing at the moment because you
would have so many other options if it
were not for coronavirus I do and I'm
and I'm not looking for any special
preferential treatment I just want equal
treatment with with the coronavirus
patients for these patients particularly
the fear is losing precious time
tomorrow Coen Sky News